ever since the walking dead first aired
in 2010
the creative minds at amc had been
quietly sowing seeds that connected the
zombie series with another amc success
story
breaking bad so what does walter white's
meth infused power trip
have to do with surviving the end of the
world
ever since the spin-off series of fear
the walking dead arrived on the scene
it's been clear that the walking dead
universe was more than just a single
show set between atlanta and washington
dc
this was confirmed when amc network ceo
josh sapan
announced in early september 2018 that
the folks at amc had plans for the
universe that extended
quote over the next decade plus while
this may have seemed odd in the shadow
of the show's faltering ratings at the
time
it kind of makes sense the idea of a
long-term goal that spans beyond the
scope of a single film or series is par
for the course in hollywood
cross-pollinating universes is totally
in these days
so a connection between amc shows is
hardly surprising
what's a bit more interesting though is
the not quite confirmed larger crossover
that integrates breaking bad into the
walking dead universe
a phenomenon fondly nicknamed the
breaking dead theory
it's been loosely confirmed by
showrunner dave erickson
and here's the skinny on how the two
shows line up
it didn't take long for the walking dead
to start incorporating elements of the
runaway hit
breaking bad into their fledgling zombie
apocalypse series
in the second episode in season two
daryl dixon can be seen rifling through
a clear bag
the contents comprise his brother
merle's stash most of which is in pill
bottles
however tucked at the bottom of the bag
is a hefty dose of some blue crystals
the shot immediately grabs your
attention as daryl casually lists
crystal among the gathered narcotics of
course the prize for the most
famous blue crystals in history has to
go to mr white's
sky blue by the end of breaking bad the
stuff was sought after all over the
world so its presence in georgia
wouldn't be particularly odd
the connection hung there for a bit
until none other than walking dead
creator robert kirkman
confirmed that the easter egg was there
on purpose it ain't cloudy or dirty or
nothing just the right shade of blue
another possible link that was picked up
on in the walking dead season 4 episode
still involved walter white's associate
mr jesse pinkman
this one came during that chunk of time
when daryl and beth were romping around
the countryside
surviving being moody and bonding like a
couple of cute misfits
in one scene daryl tells a story about
his brother merle before everything went
south
tomorrow had the stealer
this tanky little white guy
twigger fans were quick to jump on the
description as fitting pink men rather
neatly
the speculation became more intriguing a
little further into the story when daryl
explained an altercation with the fellow
in question
between the description and that line
it's hard not to start drawing a
connection
did merle work for the nefarious jesse
pinkman once upon a time
perhaps although at another point in the
story daryl refers to the guy's
kids guess we'll never know
another easter egg appeared during
season three of fear the walking dead
hidden in plain sight as the group
entered a bustling bazaar a song could
be heard
blaring over the radio it was in spanish
and to an uninformed viewer did little
more than add a mariachi style splash of
color to the scene
however for those intimately acquainted
with walter white's tragic story
arc the song had a much deeper meaning
and an undeniable connection to the
breaking bad universe
we're talking about negro iazul the
ballad of heisenberg
the song appeared as a cold open in
breaking bad and is written about walter
white
aka heisenberg chronicling his rise to
power against established drug cartels
and
predicting his eventual demise the song
is clearly specific to breaking bad and
its appearance on fear the walking dead
was a clear shout out to the connection
that the shows share
showrunner erickson was referring to
this scene in particular when he
confirmed that the nod was intentional
adding more cargo to the runaway train
that is the breaking dead theory
in season four as he continues to break
bad walter white has a growing
infatuation with indulging his reckless
nature
instead of returning a car for an
exorbitant restocking fee for instance
white simply blows it up and what about
that car a 2009 dodge challenger
red with a double black racing stripe
straight down the center
that is until it was blown to
smithereens and it wasn't the last time
one of these cars would appear on an amc
show
fast forward to exactly one apocalypse
later in the first season of the walking
dead another challenger makes an
appearance this time
roaming the streets of atlanta the car
in question is
once again a 2009 model some have taken
a gigantic
leap assuming that the mysterious glenn
who sold walter the car in new mexico
was none other than glenn rhee who fixed
it up and drove it to georgia
a more reasonable explanation might be
that glenrie the car salesman was simply
infatuated with that model
either way this nod from the new show to
the old seems
clearly intended while the little
breaking bad easter eggs sprinkled
throughout the walking dead universe are
fun to point out
the real heart and soul of the breaking
dead theory
actually rests on a crossover that's
even more sinister
it suggests that blue sky doesn't merely
link the two worlds but
that it's the cause of the zombie
apocalypse while the theory hasn't been
made official in any formal way
it also hasn't been denied by the
creators of either show
on the contrary they've stoked the fires
walking dead creator robert kirkman said
albeit a bit tongue-in-cheek
quote that's canon it's confirmed
producer galen heard when responding to
the question of what caused the virus
stated flatly quote the meth from
breaking bad for sure
on the other side of the aisle breaking
bad's vince gilligan responded to the
speculation by saying
i love that theory that was a kick
they're two great shows the walking dead
and fear the walking dead brian cranston
added
walt is dead so he could be a zombie
right now
heisenberg zombie gail was a pretty
sweet character on breaking bad he was
one of the few people who could rival
white's scientific prowess and
he could brew some darn good coffee in
fact the man had turned the ladder into
a science project with an elaborate
machine that took volume temperature
acidity and tenants all
into account in the pursuit of brewing
the perfect cup
my god that is the best coffee i've ever
tasted
while his death may have left the
breaking bad crew with cups of folger's
sludge
it appears it wasn't the last time the
scientist's magically caffeine-infused
machine was used
in the third episode of season three on
the walking dead merle the governor
and milton all gather in his lab while
they're talking in the background
is none other than gail's coffee machine
the question is
how did it get there this tie-in between
breaking bad and the walking dead goes
back
further than you might think season 9 of
the walking dead didn't just see the
departure of characters like rick grimes
it also saw the introduction of the
whisperers
in episode 10 we saw a great deal of
their leader alpha's backstory through
the testimony of her daughter
lydia during those scenes both of
lydia's parents
are seen singing
[Music]
the tune is fitting for the scene as the
girl looks for solace amidst the horrors
of the end of the world but
it wasn't just a well-placed musical
number it also of course
hearkened back to breaking bad in the
waning moments of breaking bad's last
episode
walter white stands in the midst of the
carnage he's created in his final act of
vengeance
as he parts ways with jesse pinkman for
the last time a cellphone starts to ring
on the lifeless body of todd that lies
in front of him
the tune on the cell lydia the tattooed
lady
it added an abrupt splash of colors the
series swan song as white picked up
and informed yet another lydia on the
other end of the call that her death was
imminent
the connections between amc's two
monumental worlds are
too numerous to deny and yet the
creators of both series have yet to
openly steer into the skid
walter white's world has continued on in
the form of better call saul and the
full-length feature el camino released
in 2019
in addition the walking dead has feared
the walking dead a triple header of
films in the works
and several more confirmed walking dead
series with all the material being
produced a marriage of the two universes
could be a match
made in heaven after all breaking bad
hardly closed up shop before it became
one of the cult classics of our time
and the fandoms still surrounding the
walking dead could continue breathing
life into this beloved world of the dead
for years to come
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you